le début de nos grands acteurs et oui
dans obama raconte on va voir des images
assez rare les premiers pas de nos
grandes stars devant les caméras de
casting ou en interview en 1964 jean
paul belmondo est tout jeune et a déjà
tourné dans de nombreux films il se
prête quand même à l'exercice d'un
casting un peu spéciale en belgique
regardez jean paul belmondo sont un ses
premiers castings avec beaucoup d'humour
et d'autodérision ça je sais que vous
allez kiffer on va voir les premiers
castings de toutes nos plus grandes
stars ça benjamin fall chaussures tu
dois t'y fais ça se corse à regarder
jean paul belmondo un de ses premiers
castings c'est en 64 votre nom non
pardon belmondo votre âge 20 ans
on est très vite entré chez les très
bons rené nous allons faire le test de
photogénie
monsieur le monde au souriant souriez
soucieux soucieux que tu pas les
associer aux cieux ou si méchant ça
c'est peut-être pas mal incessibles ils
se croient que vous savez conduit une
voiture
aoste oui oui mais bien la conduit
revient environ à chipoter on change de
vitesse
ouais c'est fort ça ou pas 4 j'en parle
mais ça c'est un des points 64 il était
déjà magique en 1970 pour le film est un
film s'appelait le sauveur c'est
l'histoire d'un casting pour lequel
isabelle adjani n'aura pas le rôle car
on l'a jugé trop fleur bleue ses
premiers pas devant la caméra sont très
troublant regarder elle était déjà
envoûtante et rafraîchissante
regardez ça c'est mes intérêts comme
comme martha c'est un déodorant
ah non c'est vrai regardez les premiers
pas isabelle adjani organique un casting
d'isabelle adjani c'est un de ses
premiers castings sarsgaard et fort
j'ai pensé à tout c'est pour vivre nous
volerons des tomates nous arracherons
des patates jeu les frais cuir dans la
cendre jusqu'à ce que leur peau
durcissant éclaté elles sont elles à
l'intérieur un rêve quand il pleuvra
j'ai recherché les petits champignons
blancs qui pullulent dans les prairies
je m'occuperai toi je laverai tous les
âges dans les ruisseaux
nous vivons comme robinson et creuse oui
ils vont de nouveau nous vivons comme
robinson et vendredi nous n'aurons
besoin de personne c'est je t'aime tu en
es premiers calculs isabelle adjani ben
ali oui j'en ai jamais atteint ça me
fait penser qu'on a adoré revoir les
bébés isabelle morini bosc et les le
cinématographe voilà les documents plus
est-ce que ça vous dit quelque chose ce
film au plus oui c'est qui c'est qui va
lire et mannheim sophie marceau baba
exactement sophie marceau et on est en
1980 lorsqu'elle passe ce casting pour
le rôle de vic dans la boum j'ai les
images du casting idéal de sophie
marceau pour la boue la boum vraiment
leur tout le monde connaît que vous
soyez jeunes moins jeunes très très
jeune très vieux la boum c'est universel
regarder tes toutes premières images des
castings à la 13 ans et elle est déjà
très très décontracté regardez main dans
la poche elle est tranquille c'est son
casting pour la boum
ce soir je vous raconte 12 10 les
castings et les premiers castings des
grandes stars du cinéma
regardez intéressants s'ils n'ont pu je
fais 1 m 65 jamais fait de cinéma et ça
m'intéresserait d'enfer j'ai 13 ans
c'est pas toi je crois qu'il va nous
rattraper aventis en satin parlait
encore tu fais de quitter nous parler je
vous en supplie de nous ça va ouais vous
venez lausannois pourquoi
ouais peut-être vous donner la réponse
quand exceptionnel et on la revoit le
faire dans le film sachez qu'elle avait
passé ce casting par hasard sophie
marceau elle voulait juste se faire de
l'argent de poche et se seraient ensuite
grâce à la boum 2 83 qu'elle obtient le
césar du meilleur espoir féminin julie
et c'est vrai qu'on la revoie le faire
dans le film c'est vraiment un film
culte un des dix films cultes français
oui gilles verdez alors quand vous voyez
c'est facile de réécrire l'histoire je
sais mais quand vous voyez isabelle
adjani sophie marceau à leurs débuts
même avant leurs débuts officiels
on sait déjà qu'elles seront des super
stars le charisme le regard le devant la
caméra c'est déjà d actrice
extraordinaire
regardez benjamin castaldi le regarde
c'est quelque chose qui nous ramenait
mais il a déjà le cas durant quelques
jours
merci je suis fan voilà tuba basse et
pour toi mon père j ai je suis un peu
peur plaisir mon chéri en 83 vous allez
voir le casting d'un jeune acteur qui a
15 ans alors vous savez quoi je vais
vous le montrer et vous allez essayer de
trouver de qui il s'agit il est ce qu'on
appelle un enfant de la balle puisque
ses deux parents sont comédiens et il
affirme que ce n'est pas uniquement
grâce à eux qu'il veut faire ce métier
regardez chez vous à votre avis qui est
ce comédien qui a passé un casting à 15
ans c'est un comédien que j'aime
énormément
remettez jean michel mr et à peut-être
trouvé c'est un comédien dont je suis
assez fan et c'est un regarde alors vous
savez comment je vis cognac
vi quinze ans ça commence à faire ce
métier parce que tu avais déjà familles
qui étaient dans le métier ou pas non à
l'origine c'est pas pour ça qu'il ya bon
ça va il est évidemment son âme
ça m'a motivé motivé ouais mais à
l'origine ce pas pour ça non si c'est
vraiment quelque chose que j'aime je le
sens prochaine en plus du métier tu fais
des choses dans sa vie à côté je fais de
la boxe de la danse puis la musique
qu'il était un bon y'a plein de gens sur
twitter qui me disent mes séries
inédites direct comment il s'appelle
clovis cobistes y en a pas cinquante
mille alors le siba vous avez vu cette
bonne boule clovis cornillac franchement
fort ou pas et regardez il ya pas mal de
gens qui me jean michel maire il le fait
souvent rire et ce soir j'adore quand il
est à côté de la plaque voilà même sur
la voie du kobus jeudi qui est à côté de
la plaque complètement il va revenir au
club michel je vous montrais en 85 une
actrice c'est béatrice dalle elle a 21
ans elle passe le casting pour le film
qui va la révéler au grand public le
cultive une 37 2 le matin 1 c'est un
film twilight est un bon film ça c'est
dominique besnehard qui lui fait passer
le casting je vous dis si vous avez
juste lui moi je n'ai pas bu 1 37 2 le
matin je vais juste prix n'ont jamais
alors
[Musique]
quand je crée un versant crise de ma vie
et je viens trompés et ont fait un pari
aussi lui david à paris à un appartement
puis comme il est très amoureux noah
l'esprit gâtés et puis on amorce
convaincu les parties encore un garçon
évidemment les affiches
alors si vous nous rejoignez sur s'est
vite on est en direct les cherry et on
vous montre les castings des grands de
nos grands acteurs alors là c'est pas
casting que je vous montrais c'est un
passage dans une émission américaine
d'un très grand acteur français
c'est dans le tonight show de david
letterman s'étant 90 qui c'est lors de
cette émission que gérard depardieu
s'était adoré par les américains on peut
dire que ce sont en fait ses débuts aux
états unis il vient d'être nommé pour
l'oscar du meilleur acteur pour cyrano
de bergerac berges irak bien triste ou
du cce est regardé son engrais son
anglais approximatif mais son verre
était bien remplie il était bien géré à
il a été bien reçue aux états unis où ce
avec le même gérard depardieu regardez
c'est cette télé qu'il a fait mais aux
états unis rien j'aurai des perdus
[Applaudissements]
enjoy comme des dingues des jo m'a dit
qu'il avait vu cette gueule de gérard
depardieu et c'est franchement voilà je
suis fan après lyon sera toujours fan de
lire à deux pas du parc à ce qui tue ce
qu'il veut on est on est fan de lui en
93 je vous montre si vous nous rejoignez
je vous dis les castings ou les débuts
des grands acteurs français
c'est vrai que l'on vient de voir sa
tête gérard depardieu mais là c'était
passé début c'était quand si c'était 7,7
télé qui l'a fait aimer aux états unis
là j'ai un truc c'est un casting sauvage
c'est à dire que c'est un garçon qui se
balade tranquille dans la rue à la
recherche
voilà de n'importe quoi mais il voulait
pas faire de casting et là il ya des
réalisateurs qui vous arrête qui cherche
la pépite
et voilà qui en se fiant à votre look se
disent tiens peut-être lui sera un bon
acteur et ça a été le cas pour romain
duris romain duris à 19 ans l'auberge
espagnole à vous connaissez romain duris
l'arnacoeur
au début on se demande ce qu'il fait là
et lui aussi il est face à cédric
klapisch donc le grand réalisateur pour
le film le péril jeune
regardez c'est un casting sauvage il l'a
trouvée comme ça dont la regarder ça et
ce qu'ils avaient bien oui
respectez content de l'entendre t
finalement vous avez envie de battre
parce que déjà je pense qu'en juin quand
tu vois sans joie ou babou à ce qu'ils
avancent
ou alors je suis une meuf prêt-à-porter
que je mange chez les cartons par
exemple ici des ventes a rien à dire non
si sa chan s'est notablement tous à nous
comprendre quoi comprendre ça fait trois
mois que je passe huit heures par jour
dans cette cure de mai relaté grosse
[ __ ]
bonjour savoie au change de mois d'août
fera affaire parce qu'il faut aux grands
puisque j'écoute ce genre de conneries
comme si tu veux le faire peser le plus
pour chantal goya plus de courtoisie de
problèmes chez d'école mais et c'est
vrai qu'il pouvait pas passer à côté de
son look à romain duris mais il n'aura
qu'à fait le péril jaune après qui a
fait plein de succès voilà alors je vous
le dis en 98 je vous montre une séquence
incroyable c'est audrey tautou autre
grande actrice elle se présente un
casting de jeunes premiers pour canal+
seule contrainte se raconter en une
minute et vous allez voir c'est un petit
bijou de séquences audrey tautou était
déjà un véritable ovni audrey tautou
bien sûr le fabuleux destin d'amélie
poulain entre autres lui regardez
comment ces partis une panne toute
l'espagne demande même temps une demande
serait bien difficile ce sera maintenant
possible parce que moi une minute après
plus d'une minute
c'est vrai je serai pas là raconte et au
tout tnt ou avec un thé comme
tout ça fait que ça m'arrangerait pas
être là quand eto'o tout du tout au tout
avec hâte et comme tout parce que tout
en une minute sais c'est qu'on ne mérite
pas qu'on aurait plus émis par ce serait
plus même pas s camille pas vraiment ce
mythe pas de sa forêt ponte pour voir en
même temps côté les mille pattes de
mille pattes c'est vachement sa propre
est devenu tout n'aurait pas eu le temps
non une minute pour raconter tout du
tout au tout avec un thé comme tous et
c'est comme un train congrès tu
comprendras que jamais si tu prends le
prochain ce sera plus la même sur
celui-là différentes et ne prendra plus
jamais alors qu'ils avaient plein de
choses dedans danse trân tuân raté des
choses renvoi dehors aussi parce qu'on
est dedans dans ce train et ce joli qui
font marrer des jeux doit bel qui font
pleurer parce que pleurer c'est beau
surtout quand t'as pas de larmes
c'est la montagne sans neige est
beaucoup plus jolie parce que c'est bien
plus rare remarquer
j'ai produit par mise à marcher avec
n'importe quoi d'autre tu prends le
millefeuille c'est la même chose avec
the big board
bon je m'appelle tautou avec as they
come to gecko de pâtes et j'ai pas le
temps un trajet direct voilà qui est
devenu l'immense actrice appareils 3d
c'était assez pour le casting
c'était pour catapulter